bonsoir bienvenue pour ce nouveau
journal sur tv fil 78 étaient dans
l'actualité de ce 5 mars 2015 dans les
yvelines les conséquences de l'énorme
perte de près de 5 milliards d'euros par
le géant français du nucléaire areva
areva installés à travers le monde et
notamment à montigny le bretonneux
depuis plus de 30 ans la cour d'appel de
paris a accepté la révision de
l'arbitrage dans l'affairé opposant
bernard tapie au crédit lyonnais un
arbitrage datant de 2008 est dénoncée
par le professeur agrégé de droit privé
thomas clay il est aussi le
vice-président de l'université de
versailles saint quentin vous
l'entendrez tout à leur premier temps
fort de la saison des courses cycliste
par étapes le paris nice qui va débuter
ce week end un départ donné depuis les
yvelines à maurepas plus précisément 4,8
milliards d'euros de perte et un plan de
redressement pour le géant français du
nucléaire la situation d'areva inquiète
au plus haut niveau de l'état ce jeudi
matin emmanuel macron a reçu maires
députés sénateurs représentants
syndicaux le ministre se voulait
rassurant pas de licenciements mais dans
les différents sites et notamment à
montigny le bretonneux
on reste inquiets reportage 4,8
milliards de pertes pour la seule année
fleuron français du nucléaire areva est
aujourd'hui un colosse aux pieds
d'argile détenu à 85% par l'état et
employant 30 mille personnes dans
l'hexagone
le groupe est aussi présent au niveau
industriel dans une quarantaine de pays
et dans près d'une centaine au niveau
commercial
l'annnonce de ses mauvais résultats donc
véritablement sonné les syndicats qui
s'attendent à une réduction d'au moins
15% des effectifs et notamment sur le
site de montigny le bretonneux installé
depuis 1981
la direction est assez vague il va y
avoir effectivement avec les instances
représentatives du personnel
un certain nombre de deux rencontres
tracez un accord de d'état est prévue
pour fin mars début avril
on entend bien le gouvernement qui
quitte aussi peut-être parler pour cause
d'élection ni qu'il n'y aura pas un
impact social
elle rappelle plutôt à du volontariat et
autres gars vous savez c'est ce qu'a
fait la principale crainte des syndicats
à voir les plus âgés et donc les plus
expérimentés quitter areva à montigny le
bretonneux un millier de salariés qui
travaillent pour moitié sur le transport
l'entreposage et le stockage de matières
nucléaires
les autres intervenants pour des
filiales de la multinationale pour
sortir de la crise françois hollande a
souhaité voir s'opérer un rapprochement
avec edf le ministre de l'économie
emmanuel macron évoque refonte du
partenariat mêmes rapprochement
capitalistique penser du bien pour les
secteurs dans les secteurs en
particulier dans ce secteur là
travailler sur des nouveaux raids l
ensemble est déjà passé le tout est
effectivement de voir si ces contrats
avaient forcé 6 heures aubades aviron en
2013 areva avait déjà annoncé une perte
de 500 millions d'euros
l'invité de ce 5 mars à présent thomas
clay bonsoir bonsoir professeur agrégé
de droit privé vice-président de
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en charge de
la stratégie de l'établissement doyen
honoraire également vous êtes l'auteur
de cet ouvrage imposant ouvrage le code
de l'arbitrage commenté aux éditions
lexisnexis nous vous recevons ce soir
tout simplement parce que vous êtes le
principal artisan du recours contre cet
arbitrage tapis arbitrage qui lui avait
permis de remporter 403 millions d'euros
en 2008 dans un litige l'opposant au
crédit lyonnais alors sur quoi s'est
basée la cour d'appel de paris pour
revenir sur cet arbitrage tout
simplement alors je dois quand même
corriger ou et résister mais c'est pas
de l'amour ça pas l'artisan
j étais chez lui qui a beaucoup entendu
sur cette question alors voilà je me
suis exprimé j'ai porté médiatiquement
ce recours je les portais aussi
intellectuellement
j'ai répondu aux questions qu'on pose
est quand on me posait des questions
mais il ya eu des avocats il ya eu des
magistrats qui ont quand même rendu
cette décision qui est effectivement un
arrêt de la cour d'appel de paris du 17
février dernier et qui est un arrêt qui
annule qui juridiquement rétracte maison
ça revient à une annulation
la sentence arbitrale litigieuse que
vous venez d'évoquer qui avait été
rendue le 7 juillet 2008 au profit d'un
art tapie qui avait obtenu des sommes
faramineuses à ce moment-là 405 millions
d'euros dont 45 millions de ce qu'on
appelle le préjudice moral
et bien après des années et des années
il aura fallu donc sept ans pour que ce
sentiment n'est concret pour annuler
cette sentence c'est très simple l'art
est absolument accablants -il est
méticuleusement rédigé il et il est très
intelligemment pensée il constate et il
sanctionne la fraude
il ya eu une fraude dans cet arbitrage
une collusion frauduleuse entre un
arbitre un avocat la vaunage
l'avocat de bernard tapie maître maurice
cantonaux et le bénéficiaire de cet
arbitrage c'est à dire bernard tapie il
ne fait que dire ce que certains dont
moi disait depuis des années et des
années
pourquoi pour ne pas confondre cette
procédure cet arbitrage entre guillemets
avec l'arbitrage en général qui est une
procédure qui fonctionne et dont je dois
le dire ici sur votre plateau le droit
de l'arbitrage à son pôle d'excellence
dans l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin l'équipe de
recherche
que j'anime avec d'autres et qui est la
référence en france justement ça va
devant c'est un peu la suite de mes
questions mais vous êtes aussi donc
l'auteur de cet ouvrage le code de
l'arbitrage commenté ça veut dire que
même que les limites les limites de
l'arbitrage ont été démontrées avec
cette affaire-là
non je pense pas je pense que simplement
l'arbitrage comme toute institution peu
un moment être instrumentalisée au
profit d'un d'un projet frauduleux et
que quand on est attaché à cette
institution il faut la défendre il faut
dénoncer donc la fraude et que cette
fraude soient sanctionnés nouveau procès
en septembre
on peut rien attendre quoi de ce procès
finalement la restitution aussi des 403
millions d'euros parce que pour
l'instant ce n'est pas le cas je pense
que la restitution va intervenir avant
le mois de septembre puisque en réalité
si vous voulez verra tapie a obtenu 400
5 422 403 mais en fait c'est 400 saint
sur scène sur ces chiffres là à 41
millions d'euros en 2008 aux termes
d'une décision qui a été annulée donc
quand lorsque la décision est annulée
l'indemnité produite cette décision est
également annulée donc je pense que
l'état serait bien avisé de manière
imminente de demander la restitution de
la somme sans attendre le procès au fond
ce qu'on revient en réalité là où on en
était en 2007
d'ailleurs devant dans la même course
est intéressant devant la cour d'appel
de paris en 2007 on était au bout du
processus du conflit entre le crédit
lyonnais et bernard tapie
et tout d'un coup hop on a retiré le
dossier de la compétence de la cour
d'appel pour le transmettre un tribunal
arbitral et bien cette procédure ce
retrait cette dépossession vient d'être
annulée et la cour d'appel va donc dire
si oui ou non bernard tapie a été floué
par le crédit lyonnais
c'est tout à l'heure vous n'êtes pas le
principal artisan particulier les
avocats des juges qui se sont prononcés
sur tout ça mais au delà ça vous en avez
fait un combat véritablement important
pour vous pour rétablir la justice tels
que vous l'entendez et c'est pour ça au
final c'était aussi un conflit d'hommes
avec bernard tapie
moi je ne connais pas bien à petit je me
sens très bien vous connaître quelques
fois quand on écoute ses déclarations
effectivement il m'a pris en grippe il
m'a attaqué il m'a attaqué en
diffamation en première instance en
appel sous les jeux les faits condamnée
pour cette cette procédure audacieuses
pour ne pas dire téméraire mais je ne
connais pas je n'ai absolument rien
contre lui
je pense que la discipline la matière
que je vis que j'enseigne que je
pratique comme arbitre
a été attaquée elle et qu'il fallait la
défendre alors c'est tombé dans mon
secteur de compétence donc effectivement
j'ai été identifié comme étant un des
experts j'ai pas le seul mais à partir
du moment où les journalistes vous savez
quand il on trouve un bain il continue
avec le même et que j'ai été
c'est vrai j'ai été entendu à la
commission des finances comme expert de
la commission des finances à l'assemblée
nationale et donc progressivement oui il
ya les informations qui me sont arrivées
et puis ces informations je les ai
redonné à la presse voilà les
journalistes justement qui vient de vous
voir vous définit tout de même comme un
juriste médiatique de gosses aussi un
jeu cache pas mes opinions pratique
effectivement je suis effectivement de
gauche
tout le monde le sait ça n'a rien à voir
avec ce dossier
d'ailleurs c'est pas un dossier
politique c'est bernard tapie qui
essayait de politiser le dossier
c'est pas un dossier petit d'ailleurs
dans les six personnes qui sont mises en
examen pour escroquerie en bande
organisée
il n'y a aucun politique c'est
simplement une affaire de gros sous
une escroquerie avec un instrument
qu'est l'arbitrage et moi je défends
l'arbitrage et que pensez vous justement
de cet arbitrage c'est notre question du
jour nous sommes serrés vous posez la
question dans les rues de saint quentin
en yvelines ce matin comme il ya
beaucoup d'hommes politiques qui se
gargarisent je suis fier je fais
confiance avec polka date à la justice
de mon pays donc je fais confiance à la
justice de mon pays
tout le reste c'est des hommes
politiques que magouilles ça me dégoûte
voilà je n'en dirai pas plus je pense
que c'est un voyou qu ils magouillent
bien avec tous ces hommes politiques qui
nous dirigent et qui en a beaucoup
d'autres qui devraient être mis en
examen
voilà je pense pas ça normal mais il a
touché va maintenant ça n'est pas leur
donner peut lui donner
il rendra jamais je crois qu'on lui en
veux beaucoup
1 déjà et d'une et puis on saura jamais
la vérité en fin de compte c'est
intéressant on saura jamais la vérité
chez moi je pense qu'on saura la vérité
de façon il n'ya qu'une seule vérité en
france c'est la vérité judiciaire la
cour d'appel va se prononcer mais c'est
vrai que ce vote reportage est
intéressant parce qu'on voit combien le
l'opinion est contrasté et c'est vrai
que d'un tapis est très fort pour faire
passer une idée est l'idée qui l'a fait
passer ces médias tic l'une m politique
apprécié en tout cas
oui non mais c'est quelqu'un qui a
énormément de talent incontestablement
mais l'idée qu'il a réussi à faire
passer c'est que il est peut-être un
voyou ça peut-être mais qu'ils aient
trouvé plus voyou que lui et qui s'est
fait avoir par le crédit lyonnais et ça
certains perdent personnes proches du
dossier pense que c'est une
mystification et on en a la réponse le
29 septembre 2011 2015 quand la cour
d'appel se prononce moralisation de la
vie politique c'est votre combat aussi
là c'est pas très très bon cette affaire
là pour l'image de la vie politique même
si au final la justice voilà maintenant
qu'il ya eu la vision de cet arbitrage
mais votre prochain combat
ça sera quoi écoutez on verra bien moi
je si je peux rendre service je le ferai
avec plaisir je me laisse porter un peu
aussi par les événements et par
l'actualité
mais c'est vrai que si vous avez raison
de le souligner cette affaire tapie
s'inscrit dans un dans un cheminement
politique ou plus exactement éthique
plus anciens qui consiste effectivement
à défendre un certain nombre de valeurs
et de pratique il ya encore du travail
merci thomas clavières ses revenus en
plateau et nous reprenons le cours de ce
journal la suite de ce journal c'est
avec le paris nice premier temps fort de
la saison des courses par étapes des
courses cyclistes bien sûr en europe qui
va débuter ce week end et une fois de
plus les yvelines sont à l'honneur le
prologue ce sera à maurepas métier
l'ennemi d'euros pour ce sujet le
prologue du paris-nice 2015 s'élancera
de maurepas ce dimanche le départ de ce
contre-la-montre sera donné à 13h30 dans
la rue de montfort
après une première partie dans la zone
industrielle les deux cents dix neuf
coureurs vont emprunter un espace boisé
avec une descente et un virage dans le
bois de prud'hommes rue de la butte
rouge
la première difficulté de l'épreuve
avant fort bien de repérer puisqu'ils
sur la gauche il y a un petit air plein
en pavés et dont qui empruntera une
trajectoire
donc il faudra vraiment bien de repérer
pour à l'amont en amont pour passer pour
pascal des côtes seront également au
rendez-vous de l'épreuve de 6 km 700
après une première montée dans la rue du
bois d'acacia les coureurs devront
ensuite emprunté la redoutable rue de la
tour une pente stratégiques ou des
écarts peuvent se creuser
moi je connais très bien parfois aussi
fait des courses sur ce parcours vous
êtes plusieurs tours effectivement donc
ça fait une bosse qui fait très très mal
pour un coursier lambda on va dire je
pense que les pros ils vont la passer
sur la plaque en gros plateau s'il peut
y avoir des écarts effectivement alors
minime à montsûrs 6 km 7 à grand chose
la dernière difficulté est à signaler à
deux kilomètres de l'arrivée le sprint
final s'engagera sur le chemin de paris
pour se terminer dans le boulevard
michel liseré il faudra donner un
dernier coup de pour terminer
dans les premiers
ça va vraiment
vraiment vous voyez c'est là que les
écarts se feront parce que ceux qui sont
moins bien et bien n'arriveront pas
renoncer et celui qui celui qui a la
haca la puissance pour pour le faire va
creuser à creuser l'écart après ce
prologue à maurepas les cyclistes eux
repartiront dès le lendemain de saint
rémy les chevreuse pour la première
étape de ce paris nice
le journal revient demain vendredi aux
mêmes horaires excellent de soirée sur
téléphiles vous retrouverez notamment
florane parfait pour une nouvelle
édition nouveau numéro de file echo et
puis je vous retrouve également pour le
deuxième débat de la campagne des
départementales ce soir avec les
candidats du canton de maurepas
excellente soirée